[Musik]
jara janousek dreieinhalb jahre alt
unheilbar krank die ohrringe müssen weg
eine wichtige operation steht an die
eltern witzeln ihre art die anspannung
zu ertragen
ja wir sind froh dass die operation ist
und sich auch sehr wichtig wird yara und
zieht das noch nie wieder und abbitte
nikolic endloskontrakt alles wieder hoch
und hinterfragte medien ist viel zu gut
mit der operation aus weil man wirklich
hilft
also es kommt denn so eine urangst was
ist wenn sie stirbt immer hinterfragt
sich plötzlich sah sie mich nur gold die
ältere für nicole und jan janousek haben
täglich vorhaben dass ihre tochter nie
gesund sein wird gar jederzeit sterben
könnte
wir haben familie janousek ein jahr lang
begleitet wie sie mit dieser ohnmacht
lebt dabei den lebensmut nicht aus den
augen verliert davon erzählt dieser film
[Musik]
die unheilbar kranke jara und ihre
eineiige zwillingsschwester ja in ein
herz und eine seele ist kerngesund
[Musik]
jannis ist der große bruder im bund
mittelpunkt des familienlebens ist das
hofer im wohnzimmer hier liegt jahre oft
sie kann sich nicht bewegen kann nicht
sprechen nicht selber essen
das mädchen bekam vor der geburt zu
wenig sauerstoff gehirn wurde dabei fast
vollständig zerstört doch erst nach der
geburt bekam pflegefachfrau nicole
klarheit darüber wie stark das eine
zwillingsmädchen beeinträchtigt sein
sollte die ärzte geben jahre nur tage
maximal ein paar wochen zu leben sondern
abgang ja aber ich habe immer noch ein
funke hoffnung dass es nicht so schlimm
ist es blieb bei der hoffnung
die eltern nahmen das mädchen nach der
geburt zu sterben
jaha trank überraschend an der brust
wollte leben
doch unterdessen muss sie künstlich über
eine sonde ernährt werden
sie leidet an häufigen krampfanfällen
versteifungen der muskeln an epilepsie
und nervenschmerzen ist sie wieder
großem stil die alten prognosen wie
lange jahre erleben wird gibt es keine
mehr
für die mutter ist es ein spagat
zwischen einem unheilbaren kind und zwei
gesunden die ebenfalls ihre
aufmerksamkeit einfordern kinderspital
zürich wir treffen die eltern und jahre
nach zwei monaten wieder
es geht ja schlecht sie hat unüblich
viele anfälle hat starke schmerzen
entlastung soll eine medikamenten pumpe
bringen die direkt in den bauch
implantiert wird
die pumpe soll schmerzmittel direkt in
den rückenmarkskanal abgeben abgestimmt
auf jaras bedürfnisse auch wenn lara
nicht geheilt werden kann
ihre eltern wollen ihr für die zeit die
bleibt ein möglichst gutes und
schmerzfreies leben ermöglichen
ganz im sinne der palliativen medizin
nicht ganz einfach wenn ein kind so
schwer belastet ist wie jahre
metten aufgemerkt der praxis hin dass
mit der spastik problem oft hilft für
die eltern gilt jahre muss nicht um
jeden preis leben nicole und jan haben
sich deshalb entschieden dass das
mädchen bei schweren komplikationen
nicht reanimiert wurde als wäre diese
entscheidung nicht schon schwierig genug
sie mussten dafür auch immer wieder
gegen andersdenkende ärzte kämpfen
das macht nur über lange zeit
lebenserhaltende maßnahmen achten dass
wenn man ihre nicht zur mutter für sie
sprang sie will aber wenn ihre körper
und dabei nicht nur grün schlug dass
sich länge ziehen
das lässt die ganz vieles was sind das
für haben ältere aber die ist die
steckdosen schuhe gewissen etwas mir
schon alles durchgemacht hat und was vor
allem chiara schoras tore gemacht hat
und wie viel der showkampf tatsächlich
viel gekämpft als budget haben müssen
kam für ios app jahr staaten kommt es
gar nicht so laufen sie aber meine form
halten pixi nicht
seit dem besuch im kinderspital sind
zwei wochen vergangen wochen des bangens
mit unzähligen arztbesuchen und
notfällen
heute wäre der tag der operation gewesen
doch sie wurde am vorabend abgesagt ja
rat eine schwere bronchitis mutter
nicole sagt uns die sei moralisch und
mit den kräften am ende
mindestens zwei wochen wird und dann
muss man das alles normal auf kreise
pfaffenhausen teil und einfach die viele
besucher die viele ersten die die viele
sorge die schlechte nachricht
janáceks erhalten täglich vier stunden
unterstützung der kinder spitex
zusätzlich sind sie auf private
stiftungen angewiesen um den alltag zu
berechtigen ehemann jan arbeitet
vollzeit nicole ist oft allein mit den
kindern ohne die hilfe von familie und
freunden ginge es nicht
[Gelächter]
und sie weiß also sie hätten das telefon
gerne mit schnauzer und ist wichtig dass
du da sieht oder wieder ruhe
als unterstützung
doch der weiße raum ihre hüte und ich
hunger und not am mann oder frau ist ja
ja
zu verstehen was in kindern vorgeht ist
per se nicht immer einfach
[Musik]
nicole sagt zwei jahre könne weinen und
kommuniziere mit den augen
doch nicht immer sei es einfach zu
wissen was ihr genau viele sport sich
die stürmisch und dann kommen sie auch
forscher dort sie buttons krieg ich muss
der arm brachte zum zum inneren das ist
dass ich mir gut aber sich aber nicht
sagen mich anpassen tost macht also
macht euch oder das macht weil wir
beobachten auch für uns ist die angst um
jahr an diesem nachmittag greifbar doch
einmal mehr erinnert die gesunde
schwester mit ihrem schalk daran dass
aufgeben keine option ist
[Musik]
zurück zum anfang dieser geschichte
zurück im kinderspital zürich heute wird
yara operiert sie erhält ihre
medikamenten pumpe bei einem
herzstillstand würde sie nicht
reanimiert das eine system und die
eltern haben sich darauf verständigt
ziehen am selben strang
das war noch bei der letzten op nicht so
drei stunden wartezeit gilt es nun
auszuhalten zeit um die geschwister zu
beruhigen
[Musik]
der operation zeit für einen moment der
unausgesprochen im raum gibt
schwierigkeiten schaffen wenn ich kauf
mir nicola millimeter und ihre
reaktionen ihre bitte kümmert dass man
das nicht aber und tabea stamm insofern
weil ich auf mit tempo sind ja einfach
nie weiß wie geht's weiter und
irgendwann wenn man
maßnahmen wie sehr geht wenn man
radikaler wechsel macher ihren trainer
verteilt auf familien
schlussendlich entweder grad mit dem
irgendwie auch mieter oder live
rollenspiele städtischer ich meine ich
die robust und dann zeit und so und da
und aber dann ist durch und ein honey
smacks zeit und das heißt ja nicht dass
er ein schlechter morris oder das bezirk
schlecht ist und ich muss einfach mal
gesagt deponiert ganz mallorca das jahr
jetzt haben wir den apparat ich vom kühe
halten
für nicole und die letzten zweieinhalb
jahren
[Musik]
jetzt ist es einfach nicht man sieht
gehört dazu als team ich eigentlich ja
ja ich kann ihm das auf der hochzeits
tagsüber müssen überhaupt nichts perfekt
aber wir sind perfekte team oder ganz
wunderbar weiter so schön das ist
wirklich das ist schöner oder sich sehr
stark für beide unternehmen ist wirklich
das reicht mir mit dass man weiß einfach
was ich hoffe das ist das ist das
wichtigste
genau
beust und goetsch ungefähr danke
vielmals gott im halbstunden also es
fertig alles wunschgemäß verlaufen
[Musik]
ja auch die auch sportlich ist es so
eine krasse sportlich gesehen danach
haben sie operieren nicht dass ich
wieder gesund dann ja aber so die
hoffentlich jetzt wird es besser
die operation ist überstanden
es folgt eine vierwöchige reha erst
danach wird klar sein ob und wie gut die
pumpe im bauch wirkt
[Musik]
rehabilitationszentrum des kinderspitals
zürich die vier wochen sind um sarah
darf heute nach hause auf mutter nicole
hat vier wochen hier verbracht wenn
immer möglich war auch jain auf besuch
wir sehen ja das erste mal lächeln
nicole hat viel auf sich genommen
nebst den nächten auf einem klappbett
musste sie sich von neun
familienmitgliedern sorgen lassen sie
vernachlässige die anderen kinder
man macht sich ja eh schon selber am
meisten gedanken und mir versuchte
wirklich anlegen gekratzt werden und
dass dort jetzt einfach besser und genau
mit der intensiv ärztin gridling
wochenende und die heckseite nein es ist
gut sind sie da mit ihm zufolge wissen
dass sie über erkannt
klar ist auch um möglichst schmerzfrei
leben zu können muss ja bald wieder
operiert werden vorerst an der hüfte
wir wagen die heikle frage nach der
notwendigkeit einer erneuten operation
bei einem unheilbaren kind die zutrifft
und so aber durchaus geforscht
also wenn ich sicher die mohn operiere
laut das war natürlich nicht aber dann
würde ich will dich einfach sag' ich
möchte dass sie nicht so schlimm
märz hatte stift und dann haben wir mal
hoffentlich bitte richtig
jan und jannis sind gekommen um nicole
und die mädchen abzuholen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
auch für die männer der familie war die
reha zeit strapazierend
[Musik]
jörg flecker verfügt bis zum london
weiter vermisst
und ja ob es zum mond umdreht du dir ja
das sogar bis sie der bibel zum 3
einige monate sind seit der reha
vergangen die ferien stehen an
jetzt muss bei lutz freybott er an im
aufmacher bis modern sind aber im kreis
problem gibt noch media jahre lebt es
geht ihr besser als bei unserem ersten
treffen vor einem jahr
[Musik]
das wetter in hasliberg könnte schöner
nicht sein während die gesunden kinder
in der schule sind fahren die eltern und
großmann brilliert mit jahre schlitten
yara hat auch die schwere hüft operation
gut überstanden
nach schwierigen monaten der genesung
hat sie endlich weniger schmerzen
weniger anfälle
die familie erhält seit kurzem auch
etwas mehr unterstützung bei der pflege
und betreuung von jahre weniger
schmerzen mehr unterstützung
all dies trägt dazu bei dass es der
familie heute besser geht sie sich trotz
unheilbaren kind nicht behindern lässt
den lebensmut nicht verloren hat
ballaballa qualität spielt eigentlich
auf ein solches also genau wie machen
jetzt darum ihr findet es wichtig und
das ist im moment wirklich anlagepolitik
[Musik]
sofort wurden sind